what's up guys it's Colin for the score
eSports you know csgo is built to make
highlights happen from knife kills to
one digs to tents clutch situations
there's a lot to choose from but there's
perhaps nothing sexier then the AWP
flick from op flicks that are nearly
imperceptible to one so why'd you wonder
if the Opera broke their wrist we've
compiled our list of the top 10
AWP flicks now before we do get into it
guys I'm gonna need you to go ahead and
give that subscribe button your own
flick I know that was cringy so without
further ado let's get into it with the
top ten top flicks and csgo out kicking
off our list at number 10 is Dennis who
shows us he can do it all and he's not
just a pistol God with the solo hold
from quad the Swede went on an absolute
tear mowing down for virtus pro players
to finish off the ACE gonna have to do
no smoke on him so he should just be
able to free roam with the AWP in there
we go make that four AWP prowess that's
not something you see too often but well
that was just impeccable every single
click landing and the last one is
probably the best of the long just
flicks away and a headshot why not
at number nine is this simply
unforgettable clutch from fallen who
puts on an absolute clinic during the
semi-finals of IEM katowice 2016 with
just seconds remaining in the round
fallin single-handedly keeps LG's hopes
alive with a noscope onto flamey before
landing a disgusting flick on to Edward
okay
tax up one
started to believe as well Henrique I
told you you've just gotta believe
sometimes Alex 17 HP 301 look like he
was just gonna be going for the bomb but
somehow to the sickest shots we've ever
seen that was unbelievable at number
eight we've got Guardian at Dreamhack
open 2015 the now-former Navi player is
an absolute monster as he annihilates
for Titan players one after another file
this one under just Guardian things
position it's so hard to make anything
happen and he gets look at this I'm
gonna sit back and enjoy it this shop
I'm shaking my head number seven goes to
honey at the NA qualifiers for star
series season three down twelve eight to
misfits immortals we're looking for
anything to get them back in the game
penny delivered after sick revealed his
position with a flash the Brazilian came
through with this disgusting flick
through the wall that eventually led to
a 1614 immortals comeback win what is
that what the hell pity my god at number
six we've got Savage versus Kenny s at
the star series season two final savage
went head-to-head with the French
prodigy as they met down mid for a duel
that ended with a filthy flip I'm
watching off the buyback now oh my god I
mean it's a it's a it's a flick and in
terms of degrees it might not be that
much but considering how far away it was
and how little the body here being that
coming in at number five is fanatics JW
who put on a one-man show on cash
single-handedly holding down the Beast
site at this ESL pro league season three
match facing an onslaught of SK players
JW calmly picks apart the Brazilian
attack with some crisp shots and an
otherworldly vac worthy flipping me off
since ring today I'm gonna be mating off
and JW of course lands the first shot
and he'll be fully aware
yeah all right hold on
it's like don't blink don't flake
because a double here another that's
like one of the sickest rounds number
four is none other than the flick God
himself
Kenny s known as one of the fastest
reaction shots in csgo history kenny hit
this insane flick that deletes forest
after the swedish legend pits him in
apartments changes in his face very soon
oh that is fast but that new private
slugger
i think you get pretty high if you did
that's a quite a shot from Kenny coming
in at number three we've got simple with
a flick so fast you'll miss it if you
blink a flick that needs to be slowed
down by up to three times just to see
how to save the day be 250 out and shop
through
but he looks the wrong way and simple
will continue to dance the salsa as he
steps left step drying step down
taking the runner-up spot on our list is
Drakon who in a 1v2 against gambit with
just seconds left baits out both mo and
Hobbit for a flick to remember this shot
was so good it left not only Castor's
baffled but teammates as well yeah this
is just wow all over isn't it no kit
either and now both Moe's back at the
ankle yeah this should be impossible
from the way that's a nice flick though
but still with the 10-second he's gotta
find Hobbit off to the left Oh what is
that flick from Dracon he has no idea
what just happened either that is so
sick I have no idea what I just saw
coming in at our number one spot is none
other than you guessed it kenny s kenny
put on an absolute clinic ripping apart
his fellow frenchman and former team
limb from limb with a flick so good he
didn't even need to scope it's kenny in
shucks vs. the world here in shocks
action Kenny first up the bat he finds a
shot but he's being pressured up close
he need Shox to support him he's
watching for flavor what oh my god Kenny
it's an incredible kill against sixer I
don't even see the flick he hits that
shot summit hall and it's another round
for g2 that was the craziest hop flick
I've ever seen this shot was so good
even the French casters were blown away
with what a bum cap was it
you do it ace Hood's go cool gets killed
saw Kiska sea well guys that's our list
and if you made it this far you might as
well drop a like a subscribe and a
comment and let us know what top-10 list
you want to see next thanks for watching
if you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button